[Music]
Emma you gotta help me so that I can
help you Dad why do I have to talk to
you you don't talk to me it is my job to
help keep you safe maybe you should help
yourself
it's like she's built this Fortress
around herself so that nothing can
powered her
them
um you're okay
are you okay she goes to panic attack
look at me look at me I know where
you're at
what did you say to her
[Music]
oh God hi I wanted to say sorry for
wrecking your Universe you coming in to
check on Emma was a very thoughtful
gesture I did hit you both with my car
you did and I am planning on suing
they're very easy to be in your company
you know that yeah it's
yeah it's two
why did you run away from me I'm a
complicated person it's got baggage
after the accident when I was scared he
said that you've been there too well I
have a bunch of
my life is a mess this is good
I've never shared this with anyone
before
[Music]
I'm perfect either felt like the
universe was bringing us together what
did this happen for a reason how did
your husband
died
[Music]
we are all about wolves in us we just
have to make sure you feed the right one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is who I am
[Music]